Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest ishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. the Tudors transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需获取每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国，都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。你知道吗？Hive 也经历了自己的变革。大家都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化成了更伟大的存在。能帮你用清洁能源为家庭供电的太阳能电池板，以及能从空气中汲取热量的热泵。
EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers, and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions, to deliver a quality product
还有在你睡觉时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电桩。所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家庭的力量，从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消费到贡献。所以，历史下一次伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，它可能就发生在你家里。一场没有断头台的静默革命。Hive。了解你的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive 应用程序兼容部分热泵。本期节目由 SAP 赞助。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理工资单，即使在您的业务面临多方压力时，也能交付优质产品
at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. more at sap.com slash uncertainty. With Amex Platinum, you have access to over 1,400 airport lounges worldwide. So your experience before takeoff is a taste of what's to come.
并以合理的价格，同时给予员工应得的报酬，让您的业务保持从容不迫。更多信息请访问 sap.com/uncertainty。持有美国运通白金卡，您可以在全球范围内使用超过 1,400 间机场贵宾室。因此，您在起飞前的体验将是未来旅程的缩影。
That's the powerful backing of Amex. Conditions apply. When no Carson's carriage drew up outside Neret's hotel in one of central London's most elegant streets. The pavement was packed with well-wishers. He was dressed in full uniform with three stars on his breast and two gold medals, reported the Naval Chronicle, and was welcomed by repeated huzzars from the crowd, which he returned with a low bow. He looked extremely well, but in person very thin.
这就是美国运通强大的后盾。适用相关条款。当纳尔逊的马车停在伦敦市中心最优雅街道之一的内雷特酒店外时，人行道上挤满了祝福者。据《海军纪事》报道，他身穿全套制服，胸前佩戴着三颗星和两枚金质奖章，受到了人群中阵阵欢呼的欢迎，他以深鞠躬回礼。他看起来气色极好，但本人非常消瘦。
In the hotel lobby, Fanny and Edmund were waiting, nervously wringing their hands. When they saw him, relief and joy flashed across their faces. Then two more figures came in behind him. An older man long-faced and beaky-nosed. And a younger woman. With an enormous mass of chestnut hair. and almost bursting out of her dress. And although Fanny tried to smile,
在酒店大堂里，范妮和埃德蒙正在焦急地绞着双手。当他们看到他时，如释重负和喜悦的神情在他们脸上闪过。随后，他身后又走进来两个身影。一位年长的男子，长脸鹰钩鼻。还有一位年轻女子。留着一头巨大的栗色长发，几乎要从裙子里撑破出来。尽管范妮试图微笑，
it was as if somebody had snuffed out all the lights. So that, of course, is from Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas, by our very own Dominic Sandbrook, out in paperback today. And it gives you a sense of the incredible stylistic range of this book. In the previous one, we had some vivid and highly original travel writing. Naples is a city of contrasts. And now, with this scene, we are launched into something redolent of, well, of kind of, some types might say melodrama, others more kindly might
但就好像有人熄灭了所有的灯光。所以，这段内容当然出自我们多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）所著的《时间冒险：纳尔逊，海洋英雄》（Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas），该书平装版今日上市。它让你感受到了这本书令人难以置信的文体跨度。在上一部作品中，我们读到了一些生动且极具原创性的游记。那不勒斯是一座对比鲜明的城市。而现在，通过这一场景，我们进入了一种让人联想到……嗯，有些人可能会说是情节剧，而另一些人可能会更仁慈地
say reminiscent of Jane Austen, perhaps. So the scene, it's on the 8th of November 1800. Nelson has been away for more than two years from his wife, Fanny, and his father, the vicar, Edmund Nelson, and they realize to their horror that he has brought with him to their meeting his mistress Emma Hamilton, who is pregnant by Nelson, so hence Dominic's very diplomatic description of her bursting out of her dress, and her husband Sir William, her elderly husband, Sir William. And, you know, this is either the rankest melodrama or reminiscent of Mansfield Park. Take your pick, but it's high, high drama, isn't it, Dominic? It is indeed, Tom.
说是让人想起简·奥斯汀，也许吧。场景发生在 1800 年 11 月 8 日。纳尔逊已经离开他的妻子范妮和他的父亲——牧师埃德蒙·纳尔逊超过两年了，他们惊恐地发现，他带回来的会面对象竟然是他的情妇艾玛·汉密尔顿，她怀着纳尔逊的孩子，所以才有了多米尼克对她“从裙子里撑破出来”的非常外交的描述，以及她的丈夫威廉爵士，她年迈的丈夫威廉爵士。而且，你知道，这要么是最庸俗的情节剧，要么让人想起《曼斯菲尔德庄园》。随你怎么选，但这绝对是高潮迭起的戏剧，不是吗，多米尼克？确实如此，汤姆。
We should be getting into more soap opera-style shenanigans later in this episode. But maybe first we should remind ourselves where we've got to. So this is the first time Nelson has been in England since April 1798. Listeners will recall that he chased Napoleon's fleet across the Mediterranean, destroyed them at the Battle of the Nile, then went north to Naples and was embroiled in the poisonous politics of the kingdom of the two Sicilis. And there he slightly let himself down. I think we agreed by shooting. Yeah, shooting prisoners that he said he wouldn't shoot. And then he started, or about the same time, he started an affair with the wife of the British minister
我们稍后会在本期节目中深入探讨更多肥皂剧式的闹剧。但也许我们应该先回顾一下我们进展到了哪里。这是纳尔逊自 1798 年 4 月以来首次回到英国。听众们会记得，他曾在地中海追击拿破仑的舰队，在尼罗河战役中摧毁了他们，然后北上那不勒斯，卷入了“两西西里王国”那充满毒性的政治斗争中。在那里，他稍微让自己丢了脸。我想我们一致认为是因为枪决。是的，枪决了他曾承诺不会枪决的囚犯。然后他开始了，或者大约在同一时间，他与英国驻那不勒斯公使的妻子
in Naples, Emma Hamilton, who we met earlier on. So shall we pick up the story in the late summer of 1799. Let's. So this republic that was set up in Naples, the Parthenopian Republic has been crushed. King Ferdinand and Oaf, Queen Maria Carolina, you ventriloquized her as Bill Sykes. They are back on their thrones. Nelson is the temporary commander-in-chief in the Mediterranean, but he's keeping the seat warm until casting agents' favourite Scotsman, Admiral Lord Keith, returns from leave. He is very much not a man who would look favourably on a former prostitute doing attitudes. Correct. So the priority really is the Admiralty want to retake Malta where there is a French garrison because of course Napoleon took Malta on his way to Egypt.
艾玛·汉密尔顿开始了婚外情，我们之前已经提到过她。那么，我们从 1799 年夏末开始继续讲这个故事吧。好的。在那不勒斯建立的那个共和国，即帕特诺佩共和国已经被镇压。费迪南德国王和那个笨蛋玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜王后——你曾把她比作比尔·赛克斯——他们又回到了王位上。纳尔逊是地中海的临时总司令，但他只是在为选角导演最喜欢的苏格兰人——基思海军上将——休假归来前占着位置。他绝对不是那种会欣赏前妓女摆姿势的人。没错。所以，真正的首要任务是海军部想要夺回马耳他，那里有法国驻军，因为拿破仑在去埃及的路上占领了马耳他。
And historians disagree about this and indeed Nelson's own contemporaries disagreed about it whether Nelson's heart was really in retaking mortar or whether he was distracted. I'm sure we will come to this later on. He has based himself not in Naples, but back in Palermo, where he is joined with the Hamilton's. And again, there are criticisms at the time, aren't there, that he has perhaps lost sight of his duty and that he has preferred. He prefers to moon around with Emma in Palermo than going off and attacking Naples,
历史学家对此有分歧，事实上纳尔逊的同时代人对此也有分歧，即纳尔逊的心思是否真的在夺回马耳他上，还是他分心了。我相信我们稍后会谈到这一点。他没有把基地设在那不勒斯，而是回到了巴勒莫，在那里他与汉密尔顿夫妇会合。同样，当时也有批评声音，不是吗？认为他可能已经忘记了自己的职责，比起去进攻那不勒斯，他更喜欢
But Tom, you think that's a little bit harsh. I do, because the pitch is that Nelson is Antony frolicing with Cleopatra in the fleshpots of Alexandria. That's the parallel that people endlessly, endlessly draw. But the thing is, Palermo is not at all a mad base from which to prosecute what Nelson as acting commander-in-chief in the Mediterranean sees as his responsibilities, which are chiefly to keep an eye on the endangered kingdom of Naples, and if possible to roll the French backwards up through Italy. And secondly, to maintain and coordinate the blockade of Malta because the fall of Malta will give Britain an absolute strategic naval prize. And the thing is that although Britain is funding some of the blockade, the other key person who is contributing towards this blockade is Ferdinand. And the reason he's doing that is because he basically thinks that he's going to end up with Malta.
在巴勒莫与艾玛厮混。但汤姆，你觉得这有点苛刻了。我确实这么认为，因为人们的论调是纳尔逊就像安东尼在亚历山大的温柔乡里与克利奥帕特拉调情。这是人们不断、不断引用的类比。但问题是，巴勒莫绝不是一个糟糕的基地，无法用来执行纳尔逊作为地中海代理总司令所认为的职责，这些职责主要是密切关注处于危险中的那不勒斯王国，如果可能的话，将法国人从意大利赶出去。其次，维持和协调对马耳他的封锁，因为马耳他的陷落将给英国带来绝对的战略海军奖赏。事实是，尽管英国资助了部分封锁，但另一个为封锁做出贡献的关键人物是费迪南德。他之所以这样做，是因为他基本上认为最终马耳他会归他所有。
I mean, whether he does, we will see. But I think that there are lots of people who don't understand what Nelson is facing at this time, the threads that he's holding in his hands. And so they assume, well, the only reason he could possibly have for lying in Palermo is because he's... Canoodling is the word? Yes. But, I mean, both of those things can be true at once, can they? Because it's possible that the word, good grounds to be in Palermo. And yet at the same time, there's undoubtedly an awful lot of canoodling.
我的意思是，他是否会得到，我们拭目以待。但我认为有很多人不了解纳尔逊当时所面临的情况，他手中所掌握的千头万绪。所以他们认为，好吧，他留在巴勒莫的唯一理由就是因为他……“厮混”是这个词吗？是的。但是，我的意思是，这两件事可以同时成立，对吧？因为他可能确实有充分的理由留在巴勒莫。但与此同时，毫无疑问，那里确实有大量的厮混。
Even Nelson's probably one of his most admiring biographers, John Sugden, has this stuff. He describes as a repugnant cell of self-congratulation, flattery and manipulation in the court in Palermo. And he talks about the sort of the intoxicating sultraness about the Palazzo-Palagonia, fatally attractive, like a delicious sin. Now, a lot of this, you could say, is artistic projection. and a lot of this is describing the court rather than Nelson himself, but there is a sense of the time among some of Nelson's comrades that he has succumbed to the allure.
即使是纳尔逊最推崇的传记作者之一约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）也提到了这一点。他将其描述为巴勒莫宫廷中一种令人反感的自我吹嘘、奉承和操纵的温床。他谈到了帕拉戈尼亚宫（Palazzo-Palagonia）那种令人陶醉的闷热感，致命地吸引人，就像一种美味的罪恶。现在，你可以说这其中很多是艺术投射，很多是在描述宫廷而不是纳尔逊本人，但纳尔逊的一些战友当时确实有一种感觉，认为他已经屈服于这种诱惑。
And this is the only time in his career when people make that claim, right? They never make it in any other point. That he succumbed to the allure of the exoticism and the sensuality and all of this. I think that this is a tradition that goes back. Obviously people are saying this at the time. It feeds into biographies of Nelson. throughout the 19th and 20th century, who are generally written by kind of bluff naval types. And I just don't think that they approve of Italians, of showgirls.
这是他职业生涯中唯一一次人们提出这种说法，对吧？他们在任何其他时候都没有提出过。说他屈服于异国情调和感官享受的诱惑等等。我认为这是一种可以追溯到过去的传统。显然人们当时就在这么说。这影响了 19 世纪和 20 世纪的纳尔逊传记，这些传记通常是由那种直率的海军类型的人写的。我只是不认为他们赞同意大利人，赞同那些舞女。
I think there's a kind of weird obsession with the idea that everything Nelson is doing is because he's been seduced by, A, Emma Hamilton, and B, the flesh pots of Italy, Palermo, Naples, take your pick. And the two get alighted. You know, I think undoubtedly he is having this affair, probably hasn't gone beyond the canoodling's stage by this point. But I think equally it does, you know, he can have this affair, but it doesn't stop him from being as effective and efficient and dynamic as he has ever been. And yet there are complaints from very early on from people who have gone to visit him, people who might be expected to be sympathetic to him who feel that something has gone wrong. I'll just give you a couple of
我认为有一种奇怪的执念，认为纳尔逊所做的一切都是因为他被艾玛·汉密尔顿和意大利、巴勒莫、那不勒斯这些温柔乡所诱惑。这两者被混为一谈了。你知道，我认为毫无疑问他确实有这段婚外情，到目前为止可能还没有超出厮混的阶段。但我同样认为，这并不妨碍他像以往一样高效、干练和充满活力。然而，从很早开始，就有去拜访他的人提出抱怨，那些本应同情他的人觉得事情出了差错。我给你举几个
examples. So one of them is Lord and Lady Elgin. Lord and Lady Elgin are going through Palermo on their way to Constantinople, Lady Elgin writes of Nelson and the Hamilton's and their relationship with the royal family. I never saw three people made such thorough dupes of as Lady Hamilton, Sir William and Lord Nelson. It's really humiliating to see Lord Nelson as if he had no other thought than her. This is actually Maria Carolina. Is it not a pity that a man who had gained so much credit should fling himself away in this shameful manner? Now that's not an uncommon thing to say. So the other example I was going to give you, was Nelson's old friend Thomas Trubridge, with whom he later falls out.
例子。其中之一是埃尔金伯爵和伯爵夫人。埃尔金伯爵夫妇在前往君士坦丁堡的途中经过巴勒莫，埃尔金夫人写到了纳尔逊和汉密尔顿夫妇以及他们与王室的关系。“我从未见过像汉密尔顿夫人、威廉爵士和纳尔逊勋爵这样被彻底愚弄的三个人。看到纳尔逊勋爵仿佛除了她之外别无他想，真是令人羞愧。”这其实是玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜说的。难道一个赢得了如此多荣誉的人以这种可耻的方式自毁前程，不可惜吗？这并不是什么罕见的说法。所以我打算给你的另一个例子是纳尔逊的老朋友托马斯·特鲁布里奇（Thomas Troubridge），他后来与纳尔逊闹翻了。
Trubidge wrote to him and said, please, I'm hearing really disturbing reports about you. If you knew what your friends feel for you, I'm sure you would cut out all the nocturnal parties. The gambling of the people in Palermo is publicly talked about everywhere. I beseech your lordship, leave off. Lady Hamilton's character will suffer. Nothing can prevent people from talking. A gambling woman in the eye of an Englishman is lost. Now, putting that last bit on one side, this sort of sense that is clearly current, not just among later sort of Victorian biographies or whatever, but among some of Nelson's friends that his focus isn't quite what it was, that he's keeping late hours, that, you know, maybe you can say some of this is projection and some of this is Anthony and Cleopatra, but surely not all of it, Tom.
特鲁布里奇写信给他，说：“请，我听到了关于你非常令人不安的报告。如果你知道你的朋友们为你感到多么担忧，我相信你会停止所有的夜间聚会。巴勒莫人们的赌博行为在各地都被公开谈论。我恳求阁下，停止吧。汉密尔顿夫人的名声会受损。没有什么能阻止人们议论。在英国人眼中，一个赌博的女人就完了。”现在，把最后那一点放在一边，这种显然很普遍的感觉，不仅是在后来的维多利亚时代传记中，而且在纳尔逊的一些朋友中，认为他的注意力不如从前了，他熬夜太晚，你知道，也许你可以说其中一些是投射，一些是安东尼和克利奥帕特拉的故事，但肯定不全是这样，汤姆。
No, I mean, clearly it causes gossip, it causes scandal. The two most, you know, the most famous man, the most famous woman in Britain, how? having an affair. I mean, of course. I mean, it's absolute catnip for anyone who loves a scandal. And bear in mind that that thing you read about, you know, it's shameful what's going on here. This is about Nelson's relationship to the queen of Naples. And I think that the feeling is that a British admiral should not be behaving like a flunky to rulers of some kind of tin pot, Italian kingdom. I mean, I think that's the vibe, basically. And you could argue that, that perhaps Nelson is clinging to them too closely. But bear in mind, those are the orders he's been given.
不，我的意思是，这显然引起了流言蜚语，引起了丑闻。英国最著名的男人和最著名的女人，有婚外情。我的意思是，当然了。这对任何喜欢丑闻的人来说绝对是猫薄荷。请记住，你读到的关于“这里发生的事情是可耻的”那段话。这是关于纳尔逊与那不勒斯王后的关系。我认为人们的感觉是，英国海军上将不应该像某种三流意大利王国的统治者的跟班一样行事。我的意思是，我认为这基本上就是那种氛围。你可以争辩说，也许纳尔逊与他们贴得太近了。但请记住，那是他接到的命令。
He has been told, you know, look after them carefully. And I think you can absolutely make the case in terms of military strategy that maintaining the integrity of Britain's only real ally of significance in the Mediterranean at a time when Nelson is responsible for establishing the supremacy of the Royal Navy in the face of French threats, I think. That is a reasonable strategic position to take. Now, when Keith arrives, you know, he's very disapproving of Nelson's relationship with Emma Hamilton for, you know, I mean, of course. I mean, that's his kind of moral position. But I think the much more deep-seated reason for the disagreements between the two men is that Keith isn't as convinced as Nelson is that the Italian theatre is important. His focus is much more on Mnjorka, on Spain, on Bralter, and that is a strategic disagreement. And the fact that Keith is coming to replace Nelson and that Keith is not good at handling Nelson, you know, he's not afraid to insult him,
他被告知，你知道，要小心照顾他们。我认为在军事战略方面，你完全可以提出这样的论点：在纳尔逊负责在法国威胁面前确立皇家海军霸权的时期，维持英国在地中海唯一真正的重大盟友的完整性，我认为这是一个合理的战略立场。现在，当基思到达时，你知道，他非常不赞成纳尔逊与艾玛·汉密尔顿的关系，你知道，我的意思是，当然了。我的意思是，那是他的道德立场。但我认为两人之间分歧更深层的原因是，基思不像纳尔逊那样确信意大利战区很重要。他的重点更多是在梅诺卡岛、西班牙、直布罗陀，这是一个战略分歧。而且基思来接替纳尔逊，而且基思不擅长处理纳尔逊，你知道，他不怕侮辱他，
to be rude to him, to inflict what Nelson sees as snubs only adds to the mix. And I think that Keith's criticism of Nelson, for having a relationship with Lady Hamilton, and the more general gossip is veiling deeper-seated disagreements between Nelson and his peers and immediate superiors in the Navy about the course, basically, of strategy. Well, there are a number of different things here. So one of them, amid the general swirl, is that there's a backlash more generally against the Hamilton's, and that includes Sir William, as well as Emma. So Sir William Hamilton, there is definitely a sense after the failure of the Neapolitan
对他粗鲁，施加纳尔逊所认为的冷遇，只会让情况变得更糟。我认为基思对纳尔逊与汉密尔顿夫人有染的批评，以及更广泛的流言蜚语，掩盖了纳尔逊与他在海军中的同僚和直属上级之间关于战略方向的更深层分歧。好吧，这里有许多不同的事情。其中之一，在普遍的喧嚣中，是针对汉密尔顿夫妇的普遍反弹，这包括威廉爵士，也包括艾玛。所以威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，在那不勒斯远征罗马失败后，肯定有一种感觉。
expedition to Rome. And then the huge fiasco of the revolution and the recapture of Naples, there is definitely a sense, I think, that Sir William has become much too close to the royal family and that he's slightly lost the plot. So he is replaced as ambassador effectively at the beginning of 1800, a new ambassador is sent out to replace him. And when he gets back to England, a big theme will be he doesn't get the pension he expects, and he doesn't get the peerage, expect. And there's a sense in which people like, well, the Hamilton's are useless. I mean, I hear what you're saying, but from Lord Keith's perspective, he would say, I have this subordinate who is behaving like a diva, who does not follow my orders,
然后是革命和夺回那不勒斯的巨大惨败，肯定有一种感觉，我认为，威廉爵士与王室走得太近了，他有点失去了理智。所以他在 1800 年初实际上被撤换了大使职务，一位新大使被派去接替他。当他回到英国时，一个大主题将是他没有得到他预期的养老金，也没有得到他预期的爵位。人们有一种感觉，比如，好吧，汉密尔顿夫妇没用。我的意思是，我听到了你在说什么，但从基思勋爵的角度来看，他会说，我有一个表现得像个歌剧名伶的下属，他不听我的命令，
who is now thinks himself above the chain of command, the code of behavior, that governs the Royal Navy, because yes, he's a great star and all the rest of it, but he is sometimes flagrantly disobeying my orders when I tell him, go here. Nelson has always done that. I mean, that's, that's his modus operandi. That's fine, but that's very annoying if you're commanding officer. Of course it is, but I think Keith's style of leadership is completely antithetical to the Nelson touch. He doesn't have room for it. And so they're constantly rubbing up against each other. Nelson is also, I mean, Nelson is not, he's not brilliant at his own PR, is he, because he's begging Keith the whole time to let him go home. So it's not surprising
现在他认为自己凌驾于指挥链和管理皇家海军的行为准则之上，因为是的，他是一位伟大的明星等等，但他有时公然违抗我的命令，当我告诉他去哪里时。纳尔逊一直都是这样。我的意思是，那是他的行事方式。那没问题，但如果你是指挥官，那会非常烦人。当然是这样，但我认为基思的领导风格与“纳尔逊风格”完全对立。他没有容纳它的空间。所以他们不断地发生摩擦。纳尔逊也……我的意思是，纳尔逊不擅长自己的公关，不是吗？因为他一直在乞求基思让他回家。所以这并不奇怪
that Keith thinks this guy is not fully committed. Nelson's constantly complaining about his health, about his mental health. He says he's got a pain, I've got a pain in my heart, all of this kind of stuff. And Keith looks at him, and don't forget, Keith has heard a lot of the rumours. So before Keith even arrived in January 1800, another Admiral wrote to him and said, you know watch out for this infatuation that nelson has with emma hamilton i think it's very sad that nelson should have so sadly exposed himself to ridicule and censure now you could say well you know this is just sort of moral puritanism and whatnot and then keith then arrives in palermo and says i found it a scene of fulsome vanity and absurdity and i know what you'll say
基思认为这家伙没有全身心投入。纳尔逊一直在抱怨他的健康，他的心理健康。他说他有疼痛，我的心里有疼痛，所有这些东西。基思看着他，别忘了，基思听到了很多传闻。所以早在基思于 1800 年 1 月到达之前，另一位海军上将就写信给他，说，你知道，要小心纳尔逊对艾玛·汉密尔顿的这种迷恋，我认为纳尔逊如此悲哀地让自己暴露在嘲笑和谴责之下，真是太可悲了。现在你可以说，好吧，你知道，这只是某种道德清教主义之类的，然后基思到达巴勒莫，说我发现这是一个充满虚伪的虚荣和荒谬的场景，我知道你会怎么说
that this is keith kind of cosplaying a critic in antony and cleopatra or something but that doesn't mean there's not an element of truth in it no i don't think he's doing that i think he's doing that i think he's trying to impose his authority, which is obviously what he should be doing, because he's the commander-in-chief. But the problem is that Nelson, you know, Nelson wins victories by disobeying orders. That's also always been what he does. So there's a classic example of this in the early months of 1800, and it relates to the blockade of Malta. So Keith orders Nelson to abandon Palermo and come to Monorca. Nelson predictably ignores this. He sails out, and on the 18th of February, he wins the single most decisive engagement of the entire blockade of Malta, which is the key
这是基思在扮演《安东尼与克利奥帕特拉》中的评论家之类的角色，但这并不意味着其中没有真理的成分。不，我不认为他在那样做，我认为他在试图行使他的权威，这显然是他应该做的，因为他是总司令。但问题是，纳尔逊，你知道，纳尔逊通过违抗命令赢得胜利。那也一直是他所做的事情。所以 1800 年初有一个经典的例子，它与马耳他的封锁有关。基思命令纳尔逊放弃巴勒莫，去梅诺卡岛。纳尔逊不出所料地无视了这一点。他航行出去，在 2 月 18 日，他赢得了整个马耳他封锁中最具决定性的交战，这是英国的关键
strategic objective for Britain. He meets a French relief force headed by a ship Les Geno, which is one of the two ships that had escaped destruction at the Battle of the Nile. Nelson captures it and he does this by ignoring Keith's orders and trusting to his own instincts, which is what he always does. And I think you can see there exactly the tensions that have shadowed Nelson's entire career. Resentment that his commanding officers don't respect him. His commanding officers don't respect him because he's always prone to going off and doing his own thing. Then he goes and does his own thing and it turns out brilliantly. And this is a kind of an abiding theme. So he falls out, for instance, also with Sir John Jervis, his great patron, the Earl of St.
战略目标。他遇到了一支由“热那亚号”（Les Geno）舰艇率领的法国救援部队，这是在尼罗河战役中逃脱毁灭的两艘船之一。纳尔逊俘获了它，他通过无视基思的命令并相信自己的直觉做到了这一点，这是他一贯的做法。我认为你可以在那里准确地看到笼罩着纳尔逊整个职业生涯的紧张关系。怨恨他的指挥官不尊重他。他的指挥官不尊重他，因为他总是倾向于去干自己的事。然后他去干了自己的事，结果非常出色。这是一个持久的主题。所以他，例如，也与约翰·杰维斯爵士（Sir John Jervis），他的伟大赞助人，圣文森特伯爵（Earl of St. Vincent）闹翻了，后者同样认为他令人无法忍受。
Vincent, who likewise thinks he's insufferable. Yeah, but that does not necessarily, that doesn't mean that they're all wrong and Nelson is always right. You know, Lord Keith is trying to put the interests of the entire operation, the Royal Navy, first. John Sugden, who's the great Nelson biographer, I remember describing his books as the kind of war and peace of kind of this gigantic epic. I mean, he's pretty, he is really critical of Nelson in this point. For all Nelson's self-righteousness, he must have known he was disappointing members of his profession, the brothers who had begged him to stay off Malta as well as his superiors in London. He who had once been the fleet's greatest asset was now underperforming and becoming a hindrance
是的，但这并不一定意味着他们都错了，纳尔逊总是对的。你知道，基思勋爵试图把整个行动、皇家海军的利益放在第一位。约翰·萨格登，那位伟大的纳尔逊传记作者，我记得他把自己的书描述为某种宏大史诗的《战争与和平》。我的意思是，他在这一点上对纳尔逊非常、非常严厉。尽管纳尔逊有自以为是的一面，但他一定知道他让他的职业同僚感到失望，那些曾恳求他远离马耳他的兄弟们，以及他在伦敦的上级。他曾经是舰队最大的资产，现在却表现不佳，成为了他总司令的障碍，
to his commander-in-chief, a prima donna turning into a passenger. Nelson's heart was ruling his head, but for the first time in his life, he'd become an impediment rather than an asset to the service he'd loved. Now, Tom, I totally accept that you can take a contrary view of this. Well, you can quote, suckden to a contrary view, because he also says, No one fought harder for Malta than Nelson. And that's clearly the case throughout this spell. But often he's disobeyed orders in doing so, which is... There is an example of this shortly after he has seen off the French relief force.
一个变成乘客的歌剧名伶。纳尔逊的感性战胜了理性，但他一生中第一次成为了他所热爱的服务的障碍，而不是资产。现在，汤姆，我完全接受你可以对此持相反观点。好吧，你可以引用萨格登的相反观点，因为他也说，没有人比纳尔逊为马耳他战斗得更努力。这在整个期间显然是事实。但他在这样做时经常违抗命令，这……在他送走法国救援部队后不久，就有一个例子。
And Keith explicitly orders him, you know, don't go to Palermo. But Nelson does, pleading ill health. Now, I think that that is probably genuine. Nelson does seem to have been incredibly ill at this point. To quote on this occasion, Andrew Lambert, another great biographer of Nelson, on the 18th of March, while on passage to Palermo, Nelson experienced chest pains that convinced him he was close to death. Now, it may be hypochondria. I mean, that's a massive hypochondria. But he's genuinely seems to have thought he was close to death. And I think he's exhausted.
基思明确命令他，你知道，不要去巴勒莫。但纳尔逊还是去了，借口是身体不适。现在，我认为这很可能是真实的。纳尔逊在这一点上似乎确实病得非常重。引用安德鲁·兰伯特（Andrew Lambert），另一位伟大的纳尔逊传记作者，在 3 月 18 日，在前往巴勒莫的途中，纳尔逊经历了胸痛，这让他确信自己濒临死亡。现在，这可能是疑病症。我的意思是，那是巨大的疑病症。但他似乎真的认为自己濒临死亡。而且我认为他精疲力竭了。
He's ill. People say, suggest he might have a hernia. He might have gout. I mean, I think he is genuinely ill. And thrown into the mix is the fact that Keith has not congratulated him on his victory in capturing Les Gennaro. And more than that, he has given him. as a prize to his own lieutenants so that they will claim the prize money. And you can see why this would generate bad blood between the two men. I mean, I think these are complicated waters, shall we say. And the upshot is, Keith and Nelson, you know, Keith has arrived what, the beginning of 1800. They don't get on at all well. There's constant arguments. Nelson, a lot of officers say Nelson's dallying with Lady Hamilton doesn't care. Other people
他病了。人们说，暗示他可能有疝气。他可能有痛风。我的意思是，我认为他确实病了。再加上基思没有祝贺他在俘获“热那亚号”中的胜利。不仅如此，他还把它作为奖品给了他自己的副官，以便他们能获得奖金。你可以看出为什么这会在两人之间产生积怨。我的意思是，我认为这些水域很复杂，我们可以这么说。结果是，基思和纳尔逊，你知道，基思在 1800 年初到达，他们根本合不来。不断有争吵。纳尔逊，很多军官说纳尔逊与汉密尔顿夫人厮混，不在乎。其他人
say, no, that's fine. He's great. It's all going well. But Nelson, by about the middle of the year, is constantly saying, I've had enough. I want to go home. Please let me go home. And eventually, Keith says, yeah, fine. You know, I'm sick of you. Good riddance to you. And actually, even how the question of getting home, there's sort of an argument about that. So Keith says to Nelson, I'll give you a frigate. You can go home in a frigate. Now, Nelson says, oh, what, a frigate? You know, I is a great star. The Hamilton's, these tremendous people, should be going home in splendor. And actually, as it turns out, Emma doesn't want to go by C at all, does she?
说，不，那没关系。他很棒。一切都很顺利。但纳尔逊，到年中左右，一直在说，我受够了。我想回家。请让我回家。最终，基思说，好吧，行。你知道，我厌倦你了。滚吧。事实上，甚至关于如何回家的问题，也有某种争论。所以基思对纳尔逊说，我会给你一艘护卫舰。你可以坐护卫舰回家。现在，纳尔逊说，哦，什么，护卫舰？你知道，我是一位伟大的明星。汉密尔顿夫妇，这些了不起的人，应该以辉煌的方式回家。事实上，事实证明，艾玛根本不想走海路，对吧？
Partly because she knows that Maria Carolina, her great friend, is planning a trip to Vienna, great Habsburg capital. And she would really like to go on land with Maria Carolina. Now, as we will discover, Emma is also pregnant. So that is another issue. anyway, Nelson says, fine, you know, we'll go over land, we'll go via Austria, we'll go via Germany, and then, you know, cross the North Sea to England. And I think there's a, do you not agree that this is seen as generally undignified? Undignified.
部分原因是她知道玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，她最好的朋友，正计划去维也纳，伟大的哈布斯堡首都。她真的很想和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜一起走陆路。现在，正如我们将发现的那样，艾玛也怀孕了。所以这是另一个问题。无论如何，纳尔逊说，好吧，你知道，我们会走陆路，我们会经过奥地利，我们会经过德国，然后，你知道，穿过北海到英国。而且我认为有一个……你不觉得这被普遍视为有失尊严吗？有失尊严。
Yes, I do. It's not fitting for the naval, the guy who won the Battle of the Nile should come home, you know, land at Portsmouth, all of that stuff. But actually, you know, there is a sense, I think, what, and Maria Carolina want, Emma and Maria Carolina get with this? And I think also there's a sense that he's been led into bad habits by foreigners bedecking him with baubles and comical medals and things. He looks like carrots from Gilbert and Sullivan, I think, at this point.
是的，我同意。对于海军来说，赢得尼罗河战役的人不应该这样回家，你知道，在朴茨茅斯登陆，所有那些东西。但实际上，你知道，有一种感觉，我认为，艾玛和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜想要什么，她们就得到了什么？而且我认为还有一种感觉，他被外国人带坏了，他们用小玩意儿、滑稽的奖章之类的东西装饰他。我觉得他此时看起来就像吉尔伯特与萨利文（Gilbert and Sullivan）歌剧里的卡罗特（Carrots）。
Yeah, and this is felt to be kind of undignified. And I think this undoubtedly poisons the otherwise kind of complete mood of approbation that would be greeting him. I think there is a kind of undertow of anxiety that he is making himself look ridiculous, that he's letting himself down. And it obscures the fact that actually his term as commander in chief has not remotely been a disaster. So he's actually, he has kept Sicily and in the fight. He's got Naples back.
是的，这被认为是有失尊严的。而且我认为这无疑毒害了本应迎接他的那种完全赞许的氛围。我认为有一种焦虑的暗流，认为他让自己看起来很可笑，他在自毁前程。这掩盖了一个事实，即他作为总司令的任期远非灾难。所以他实际上，他让西西里岛留在了战斗中。他夺回了那不勒斯。
And he's prosecuted the blockade of Malta with extreme efficiency and with such effectiveness that actually shortly after he's departed, so on the 5th of September 1800, Malta will surrender, and rather than hand it over to King Ferdinand, the British keep it, much to everyone's surprise. And basically, they will keep it for a century and more. It will play its part in the Second World War. But actually, the even bigger thing, surely, is that Nelson is returning to England as the victor of the Nile. The winner of the greatest naval victory in Britain's history, the victory that effectively
他以极高的效率和有效性执行了对马耳他的封锁，以至于在他离开后不久，即 1800 年 9 月 5 日，马耳他投降了，英国人保留了它，而不是把它交给费迪南德国王，这让所有人都感到惊讶。基本上，他们将保留它一个多世纪。它将在第二次世界大战中发挥作用。但实际上，更重要的事情，肯定是纳尔逊作为尼罗河的胜利者返回英国。英国历史上最伟大的海军胜利的赢家，这场胜利有效地
punctured Napoleon's dreams of empire in Egypt. And the tragedy, I think, and this is even for his critics within the Navy, for Lord Keith and all these other people, that as they see it, the tragedy is that the victor of the Nile has tarnished his own record and is going back, you know, whether he's tarnished it, whether he really has tarnished it, Tom, sure we can debate. But the sadness is that he's not going back as the victor of the Nile. He's going back as a scandal-plagued, you know, controversy, haunted figure. From Nelson's point of view, there is positive to travelling over land, which is that obviously he will have to go via Austria and other parts of Germany that are allied to Britain, all of whom are very excited by his achievement in defeating the French at the Battle of the Nile.
刺破了拿破仑在埃及的帝国梦想。我认为悲剧在于，即使对于他在海军内部的批评者，对于基思勋爵和所有这些人来说，悲剧在于尼罗河的胜利者玷污了自己的记录，并且正在回去……无论他是否玷污了它，无论他是否真的玷污了它，汤姆，当然我们可以辩论。但悲剧在于他不是作为尼罗河的胜利者回去的。他是作为一个被丑闻缠身、争议不断的形象回去的。从纳尔逊的角度来看，走陆路有积极的一面，那就是显然他将不得不经过奥地利和德国其他与英国结盟的地区，所有这些地区都对他击败法国人的尼罗河战役成就感到非常兴奋。
And so yet again, it promises opportunities for being praised by foreigners, which I think by this point Nelson is very keen on. By the time they get to, you know, we don't need to go through every single place they stopped out. But they go through Italy, Tuscany, they end up in Austria and Vienna. He goes to the theatre, he has his portrait painted. He meets Joseph Hayden, who names a mass after him. He's a big celebrity, and everyone's very excited, and they're wearing kind of Nelson fashions and stuff like that, aren't they? And Emma Hamilton fashions as well. So she, too, is a big star.
所以再一次，这提供了被外国人称赞的机会，我认为到这一点，纳尔逊非常热衷于此。当他们到达，你知道，我们不需要经历他们停留的每一个地方。但他们经过意大利、托斯卡纳，最终到达奥地利和维也纳。他去剧院，他让人画了他的肖像。他遇到了约瑟夫·海顿，海顿以他的名字命名了一部弥撒曲。他是一位大名人，每个人都非常兴奋，他们穿着某种纳尔逊时尚之类的东西，不是吗？还有艾玛·汉密尔顿时尚。所以她也是一位大明星。
You know, women in Vienna are copying her look as well. They are being treated as stars, and I think both of them absolutely adore it. I mean, I worked out how much this trip costs them. This trip costs them $3,000. And if you compare that in income terms, that's about $5 million today. That's a very expensive trip. And that's money that they don't really have. So there's that issue. Second issue, Emma heavily pregnant, as you mentioned, and people are already gossiping that Nelson may be the father. He is the father. Their child was conceived while they were cruising, I think, off Malta. in the Mediterranean, and I think it's in Vienna, you get the senses in Vienna that he first
你知道，维也纳的女性也在模仿她的装扮。他们被当作明星对待，我认为他们两个都绝对喜欢它。我的意思是，我计算了这次旅行花了他们多少钱。这次旅行花了他们 3,000 英镑。如果你在收入方面进行比较，那相当于今天的 500 万英镑。那是一次非常昂贵的旅行。那是他们并没有真正拥有的钱。所以有那个问题。第二个问题，艾玛怀孕了，正如你提到的，人们已经在八卦纳尔逊可能是父亲。他确实是父亲。他们的孩子是在他们巡航时怀上的，我想，是在马耳他附近。在地中海，而且我认为是在维也纳，你感觉到在维也纳他第一次
notices. Nelson is not a man who enjoys being laughed at. And it's clear that it's about now that people do start to laugh at him. The reports of him at balls, at banquets and things, Emma's chattering away as she always does. And he's standing there sort of silent. And I think I have a sort of sense of him, you know, glancing over his shoulder, noticing people laughing, behind their hands, and he doesn't like it. Well, I think also in, particularly in Vienna, he's meeting with very high-born British aristocrats who, of course, are contemptuous of Emma, basically for being a barmaid. Nelson has his friend, Lord Minto, who's there, who says, you know, unbelievably coarse,
注意到了。纳尔逊不是一个喜欢被嘲笑的人。很明显，大约从现在开始，人们确实开始嘲笑他了。关于他在舞会、宴会上的报道，艾玛像往常一样喋喋不休。而他站在那里，某种程度上沉默着。而且我有一种感觉，你知道，他瞥了一眼肩膀，注意到人们在背后嘲笑，他不喜欢这样。好吧，我认为在维也纳，他遇到了非常高贵的英国贵族，他们当然蔑视艾玛，基本上因为她是个酒吧女招待。纳尔逊有他的朋友，明托勋爵（Lord Minto），他在那里，他说，你知道，难以置信的粗俗、
Pauling, vulgar woman. Yes. And while Emma was in Italy, you know, her Lancastrian accent had no cut through with the Italians. I mean, it meant nothing to them. But now he's being reintegrated into high society, English high society. All those reserves of snobbery are kind of waiting to come out again. Well, the issue of manners and showiness starts to become a real issue the further north they go. So, for example, when they get to Prague or to Dresden, there are British visitors, British aristocrats or diplomats who then start writing back to London and saying,
令人厌恶、庸俗的女人。是的。当艾玛在意大利时，你知道，她的兰开夏口音对意大利人来说没有任何穿透力。我的意思是，这对他们来说毫无意义。但现在他正在被重新融入上流社会，英国上流社会。所有的势利储备都在等着再次爆发。好吧，礼仪和炫耀的问题在他们越往北走时越成为一个真正的问题。所以，例如，当他们到达布拉格或德累斯顿，有英国游客，英国贵族或外交官，他们开始写信回伦敦说，
God, they're absolutely ghastly. So here's an example. Lady Hamilton declared she was passionately fond of champagne took such a portion of it as astonished me. Lord Nelson was not behindhand, calling more vociferously than usual for songs in his own praise. Now, that to me does actually ring true because Nelson does like a lot of praise. And Lady Hamilton, you feel, is not a woman who's going to stop drinking champagne just because she's pregnant, we'll say. Right, exactly. And I think, I mean, even now in England, there is a sense that you shouldn't be the first to call. Or for a song in your own praise. Tom, if you did that at a rest his history dinner, I would be...
上帝，他们绝对太糟糕了。这是一个例子。“汉密尔顿夫人宣称她非常喜欢香槟，喝了那么多，让我感到惊讶。纳尔逊勋爵也不甘示弱，比平时更响亮地要求唱赞美他自己的歌。”现在，这对我来说确实听起来是真的，因为纳尔逊确实喜欢很多赞美。而且汉密尔顿夫人，你觉得，不是一个会仅仅因为怀孕就停止喝香槟的女人，我们这么说吧。对，完全正确。而且我认为，即使现在在英国，也有一种感觉，你不应该第一个要求
Dominic, I would never do that. I mean, the one thing actually this podcast is not known for is self-congratulation. People often criticise us for too much humility. I think on this one level, we have behaved better than Nelson. However, we must always bear in mind that he did defeat the French at the Battle of the Nile. And he did secure Malta for the Royal Navy. Yeah, desperate to hammer home this Malta point on you, I can tell. Well, it's so important.
唱赞美你自己的歌。汤姆，如果你在《历史的余味》晚宴上那样做，我会……
And it's overlooked. Anyway, they travel through Europe. They get to Germany and they catch a boat back to Yarmouth. It's a packet boat. It's not a great ship of the Royal Navy. However, when Nelson lands, it doesn't matter. He's greeted the returning hero, right? Yes, there are huge crowds.
多米尼克，我永远不会那样做。我的意思是，这个播客实际上不以自我吹嘘而闻名。人们经常批评我们太谦虚了。我认为在这一层面上，我们表现得比纳尔逊好。然而，我们必须始终记住，他确实在尼罗河战役中击败了法国人。而且他确实为皇家海军确保了马耳他。是的，我看得出来你非常渴望向我强调这个马耳他点。好吧，它太重要了。
It's brilliant. It's brilliant. But at the back of his mind, surely, he's got his heavily pregnant mistress and her elderly husband. And that's a slightly odd menage with which to return to... Just to explain for people who aren't familiar with the geography of East Anglia, Yarmouth is the nearest port to the vicarage where both Fanny and Nelson's father are waiting for him or are they Dominic? Because there's kind of a mix-up, isn't there? There's a massive mix-up because
而且它被忽视了。无论如何，他们穿越欧洲。他们到达德国，然后乘船回到雅茅斯。那是一艘邮船。它不是皇家海军的一艘伟大的船。然而，当纳尔逊登陆时，这并不重要。他被迎接为归来的英雄，对吧？是的，有巨大的人群。
actually Fanny has also got him a country house called Roundwood, which is in Suffolk, which she's been preparing. They never live at it, as it turns out. And there's a great confusion. Are they going to meet there? Are they going to meet in London? Fanny's down in London. Nelson goes to the house. There's nobody there. He's very offended. You can imagine Nelson. He's used to flattery. He's used to be in the center of attention. He arrives at the house and there's no one there to greet him. Anyway, Fanny has been waiting all this time and to remind people about Fanny. Fanny is very shy, kind of quiet. If you had to criticize Fanny, which I hate to do, but I will force myself for the good of the podcast. She's perhaps a little bit boring. He married her in the
太棒了。太棒了。但在他的脑海深处，肯定有他怀孕的怀孕情妇和她年迈的丈夫。带着这样一个奇怪的组合回到……只是为了向不熟悉东安格利亚地理的人解释一下，雅茅斯是离牧师住宅最近的港口，范妮和纳尔逊的父亲都在那里等他，还是他们，多米尼克？因为有一种混乱，不是吗？有一个巨大的混乱，因为
Caribbean. They came home to England. He nursed when he was injured. She's become a second daughter to his father, and Fanny has become increasingly anxious in recent months. Nelson's letters have A started to dry up, but B, when they do come, they are very short and they are very cold. And she says to her friends, I'm actually quite worried about these Hamilton's. There's a clear sense of kind of growing dread in Fannie's mind about the influence of the Hamilton's. Now, we're not going to degenerate into Team Emma and Team Fanny, are we, Tom? I hope. I've always mentioned Mansfield Park at the start of this episode, Jane Austen's novel. Jane Austen, of course, had a brother who served in the Royal Navy, kept very abreast of
实际上范妮也为他准备了一座叫“圆木”（Roundwood）的乡村别墅，在萨福克郡，她一直在准备。事实证明他们从来没住过。而且有一个巨大的困惑。他们要在那里见面吗？他们要在伦敦见面吗？范妮在伦敦。纳尔逊去了那所房子。那里没有人。他非常生气。你可以想象纳尔逊。他习惯了奉承。他习惯了成为关注的中心。他到达房子，没有人迎接他。无论如何，范妮一直在等待，提醒人们关于范妮的事。范妮非常害羞，有点安静。如果你必须批评范妮，我讨厌这样做，但我会为了播客的利益强迫自己。她也许有点无聊。他在加勒比海娶了她。他们回到英国。他受伤时她照顾他。她成了他父亲的第二个女儿，而且范妮在最近几个月变得越来越焦虑。纳尔逊的信件开始干涸，而且当它们确实来的时候，它们非常简短，非常冷淡。她对她的朋友说，我实际上很担心这些汉密尔顿夫妇。在范妮的心中有一种明显的日益增长的恐惧感，关于汉密尔顿夫妇的影响。现在，我们不会堕落到“艾玛队”和“范妮队”吧，汤姆？我希望。我在本期节目开始时提到了《曼斯菲尔德庄园》，简·奥斯汀的小说。简·奥斯汀，当然，有一个在皇家海军服役的兄弟，一直非常了解
Nelsoniana. And I've always wondered whether Fanny Price in Mansfield Park, who is the, you know, the slightly mousy, slightly, you know, the poor relation. not showy at all, and she's counterpointed to a much more glamorous woman in the form of Mary Crawford. And I've always wondered, there's a little hint there, perhaps, of the dynamic between Fanny Nelson's wife and Emma Nelson's mistress. Well, it feels like a very Jane Austen dynamic germany, doesn't it? The two women, the one who is kind of quieter and more retiring, the one who is louder and, you know, is a little bit more Emma Woodville or whatever. Yeah, Emma, again, yeah. Yeah. Anyway, finally they all meet up.
尼尔森尼亚。我一直很好奇《曼斯菲尔德庄园》里的范妮·普莱斯，她是个有点胆小、有点……你知道的，穷亲戚，一点也不显眼，而且她与玛丽·克劳福德那种光芒四射的女性形成了鲜明对比。我一直觉得，这里面或许有一点点暗示，暗示了范妮·尼尔森的妻子和艾玛·尼尔森的情妇之间的那种动态。嗯，这感觉非常像简·奥斯汀式的动态，不是吗？两个女人，一个比较安静、内敛，另一个比较张扬，你知道的，有点像艾玛·伍德豪斯之类的。是的，又是艾玛。是的。总之，最后她们都见面了。
the scene you described at the beginning. So little of this is private because even at that first meeting, there are loads of well-wishers there. There are great crowds outside. It's actually almost impossible for Fanny and Horatio to find a moment to talk together, you know, just the two of them, because he's got his father there, because the Hamilton's are there. Nelson, when he arrives in London, he's so famous at this point. There's Nelson crockery. There are Nelson hats. There's Nelson earrings. There's Nelson Prince. He can't walk down the street without people mobbing him. And of course, he doesn't want to because he's wearing his full dress uniform. He's courting. Oh, I hate the way, I keep being noticed. Exactly. Because he's a big star and because he's Britain's
你开头描述的那个场景。这其中很少有私密可言，因为即使在第一次见面时，也有很多祝福者在场。外面有大批人群。事实上，范妮和霍雷肖几乎不可能找到片刻时间单独交谈，你知道的，就他们俩，因为他父亲在场，因为汉密尔顿夫妇也在场。尼尔森到达伦敦时，他此时已经非常出名了。有尼尔森陶器，有尼尔森帽子，有尼尔森耳环，有尼尔森版画。他走在街上，人们就会围住他。当然，他也不想这样，因为他穿着全套礼服。他在求爱。哦，我讨厌这种一直被关注的感觉。没错。因为他是个大明星，而且因为他是英国的
great military assets, he's politically important now in a way that he wasn't before. So he gets to meet the Prime Minister William Pitt and the guy who's going to become Prime Minister Henry Addington. My sense of it at this point is Nelson's greeting the crowds and he's greeting politicians, but hanging over him the whole time is this hideous dilemma, this issue of the mistress and the wife. And the fact that they're all together. I mean, that's what's so strange about it, isn't it? Yeah. And the agony of it for Nelson, I mean, setting Fanny aside, is that he knows his responsibility and his duty. He should clearly, you know, stay true to his wedding fowls, but he feels such a passion for Emma. And so he's torn in two.
伟大的军事资产，他现在的政治地位比以前重要得多。所以他得以见到首相威廉·皮特和即将成为首相的亨利·阿丁顿。我此时的感觉是，尼尔森在向人群致意，也在向政客们致意，但一直笼罩在他心头的，是这个可怕的困境，即情妇和妻子的问题。而且事实上她们都在一起。我的意思是，这才是最奇怪的地方，不是吗？是的。对尼尔森来说，这种痛苦，我的意思是，撇开范妮不谈，他知道自己的责任和义务。他显然应该，你知道的，忠于他的结婚誓言，但他对艾玛怀有如此强烈的激情。所以他被撕裂成了两半。
and it's a nightmare situation for him. It is, however, even more, I think, of a nightmare situation for Fanny. Oh, I mean, the fact that it's public, I think that's the thing, that they're forced to go to all these dinner parties where, I mean, there's dinner parties where she's seen in tears. There's this awful story about going to see a musical at the Drury Lane Theatre, Tom, where we've performed, and she faints halfway through and had to be carried out. And people said afterwards, oh, the line at which she fainted.
对他来说，这是一种噩梦般的处境。然而，我认为这对范妮来说更是一种噩梦般的处境。哦，我的意思是，它是公开的，我认为这才是关键，他们被迫参加所有这些晚宴，我的意思是，在有些晚宴上，人们看到她泪流满面。有一个关于去德鲁里巷剧院看音乐剧的可怕故事，汤姆，就是我们表演过的地方，她在中途晕倒了，不得不被抬出去。人们事后说，哦，她晕倒的那句台词。
was in exchange about an injured woman's fury. You know, this sort of idea that, and the sense I think that Fanny clearly has a very retiring person that everybody is staring at her and laughing at her. And all the time, of course, Nelson is treating her more and more coldly because he's resentful of the whole situation. And he's not a naturally cruel man, so he then feels bad about it.
是在一段关于受伤女性愤怒的对话中。你知道，这种想法，以及我认为范妮显然是一个非常内敛的人，每个人都在盯着她看，嘲笑她。当然，尼尔森一直对她越来越冷淡，因为他对整个局面感到不满。他天生不是一个残忍的人，所以他事后会感到难过。
Because he feels bad about it, he blames Fanny. And so it's a kind of vicious cycle. It's a classic pattern. And of course, this is setting up for, at the time of year where families love to get together and have massive rouse, which is Christmas. And Nelson hasn't spent Christmas with, you know, with Fanny, with his father for, what, three years now. But the 20th of December comes and he tells Fanny, I'm not having Christmas with you. Do you know where he's off to?
因为他感到难过，他反而责怪范妮。所以这是一种恶性循环。这是一种典型的模式。当然，这正值家庭喜欢聚在一起大吵大闹的季节，也就是圣诞节。尼尔森已经有，你知道的，有三年没和范妮、和他父亲一起过圣诞节了。但12月20日到了，他告诉范妮，我不和你一起过圣诞节。你知道他要去哪吗？
He's off to Wiltshire and the Salisbury area. It's great to have Wiltshire and the Salisbury area back on the show, isn't it? It is. So he goes off to Salisbury with the Hamilton's and he gets given the freedom of the city of Salisbury. So that reflects very well on Salisbury. And then he goes off to a place where I once took five wickets, Fonthill, where William Beckford, who is going to be exposed as the Jeffrey Epstein of the of the regency period, this very, very sinister figure who will end up going to exile in Portugal. But at this point, he's used all the money he's made from sugar, so exploiting
他要去威尔特郡和索尔兹伯里地区。节目里能再次提到威尔特郡和索尔兹伯里地区真是太好了，不是吗？确实。所以他和汉密尔顿夫妇去了索尔兹伯里，并被授予了索尔兹伯里市的荣誉市民权。这让索尔兹伯里很有面子。然后他去了我曾经拿过五个三柱门的地方，丰希尔，威廉·贝克福德就在那里，他后来被揭露为摄政时期的杰弗里·爱泼斯坦，这个非常、非常阴险的人物，最终流亡葡萄牙。但此时，他已经用从糖业赚来的钱，也就是剥削
slaves in the Caribbean, to build this enormous folly, Font Hill Abbey. And, and he's used, and And he lays on an absolute extravaganza for Nelson and the Hamilton's. And it's a very, very spectacular Christmas. And it's very, very not Fanny. It's very Peter the Great, isn't it? There's a lot of dwarves. There's people with torches. There's sort of strange scenes and sort of Emma does her attitudes.
加勒比海的奴隶，建造了这个巨大的愚蠢建筑，丰希尔修道院。而且，他为尼尔森和汉密尔顿夫妇举办了一场绝对的盛宴。这是一个非常、非常壮观的圣诞节。而且这非常、非常不像范妮。这非常彼得大帝，不是吗？有很多侏儒。有人拿着火炬。有一些奇怪的场景，艾玛表演了她的姿态。
She is eight months pregnant. She does Agrippina bringing the ashes of Germanicus. So tremendous scenes. Now, you can imagine Fanny's, where's Fanny? I mean, she's sort of hanging around with Ed. at age 78, a Christmas, really miserable Christmas, knowing that Nelson is away sort of with the Hamilton's at this party. And I think there's this sort of sense that the end is coming. And then the day newman comes. So on the 9th of January, Fanny and Nelson agreed to sell this
她怀孕八个月了。她表演了阿格里皮娜带着日耳曼尼库斯的骨灰。真是了不起的场景。现在，你可以想象范妮，范妮在哪里？我的意思是，她在圣诞节期间和埃德混在一起，真的很痛苦，因为知道尼尔森在外面和汉密尔顿夫妇参加这个派对。我认为有一种结局即将来临的感觉。然后结局来了。所以1月9日，范妮和尼尔森同意卖掉这栋
house roundwood that they'd never actually lived in. And a few days later, they're having breakfast with their lawyer. Nelson mentions a breakfast something about dear Lady Hamilton. And it's clear that basically for the only time in her life, something snapped in Fanny. And she said, you know, it's like the sort of the mouse that roared. She said, I'm sick of hearing of dear Lady Hamilton. And I'm resolved, you shall give up either her or me. This is the lawyer reporting this. And Nelson stared at her very coldly.
他们从未真正住过的圆木屋。几天后，他们和律师一起吃早餐。尼尔森在早餐时提到了关于亲爱的汉密尔顿夫人的事。很明显，基本上这是她一生中唯一一次，范妮崩溃了。她说，你知道，就像那种咆哮的老鼠。她说，我厌倦了听到亲爱的汉密尔顿夫人。我决定，你必须放弃她或者我。这是律师报告的。尼尔森非常冷漠地盯着她。
And he said, take care, Fanny, what you say. I love you sincerely, but I cannot forget my obligations to Lady. Hamilton or speak of her otherwise than with affection or admiration. And Fanny at that just gets up and walks out of the room. At that point, they'd been married for 15 years, and probably neither of them really knew it, but that was the end of their life together. So incredible kind of emotional storms raging there. But Dominic, out across the continent of Europe, storm clouds are gathering, and these are, of course,
他说，范妮，说话小心点。我真诚地爱你，但我不能忘记我对汉密尔顿夫人的义务，也不能不怀着爱慕或钦佩之情谈论她。范妮听了就站起来走出了房间。那时，他们已经结婚15年了，可能他们俩都没意识到，但那是他们共同生活的终结。那里爆发了令人难以置信的情感风暴。但是多米尼克，在欧洲大陆，风暴云正在聚集，当然，这些是
the storm clouds of war, and they are gathering in particular over the freezing waters of the Baltic. So after the break, we will join Nelson as he turns his back on all the emotional complications of his relationship with Fanny and with Emma, and sails east towards Denmark and the Battle of Copenhagen. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Now, thrillingly, this name Vanguard was inspired by HMS Vanguard, the flagship of none other than Admiral Nelson. He pursues the French to Abacier Bay on the shores of Egypt for the Battle of the Nile, save the world from Napoleon, really, so great scenes. So tremendous record there from Vanguard, a ship that certainly saw no lack of action.
战争的风暴云，它们特别聚集在波罗的海冰冷的水域上。所以休息之后，我们将加入尼尔森，他将背弃与范妮和艾玛关系中的所有情感纠葛，向东航行，前往丹麦和哥本哈根战役。本集由先锋集团赞助。现在，令人兴奋的是，这个名字“先锋”的灵感来自于先锋号战舰，也就是尼尔森海军上将的旗舰。他追击法国人到埃及海岸的阿布基尔湾进行尼罗河战役，真正从拿破仑手中拯救了世界，真是伟大的场景。先锋号的记录真是太了不起了，这艘船确实经历了无数战斗。
Yes. Now, speaking of action, if you want to put your financial plans into action, but you've been putting off, sorting out your ISA. Or, if you're new to investing and you don't know where to start, Vanguard offers a range of ISA options, including their managed ISA, which could be a great fit. So essentially, it's stocks and shares ISA, but it is managed by the experts of Vanguard. They'll help you to work out your risk appetite, match you to an investment plan that is right for you, and then they will do the rest. search a fangard to find out more when investing your capital is at risk tax rules apply this episode is brought to you by peloton
是的。说到行动，如果你想把你的财务计划付诸行动，但你一直推迟整理你的个人储蓄账户（ISA）。或者，如果你是投资新手，不知道从哪里开始，先锋集团提供一系列ISA选择，包括他们的管理型ISA，这可能非常适合你。所以本质上，它是股票和份额ISA，但由先锋集团的专家管理。他们会帮你算出你的风险承受能力，为你匹配适合你的投资计划，然后他们会完成剩下的工作。搜索先锋集团了解更多信息，投资资本有风险，税收规则适用。本集由Peloton赞助。
a new era of fitness is here introducing the new peloton cross-training tread plus powered by peloton iq built for breakthroughs with personalized workout plans real-time insights and endless ways to move lift with confidence while peloton IQ counts reps corrects form and tracks your progress let yourself run Run, lift, flow, and go. Explore the new Peloton cross-training tread plus at onepeloton.ca. Maybe it's just a phase you're going through. You'll get over it. I can't help you with that.
健身的新时代来了，隆重推出全新的Peloton交叉训练跑步机Plus，由Peloton IQ驱动，为突破而生，提供个性化的锻炼计划、实时洞察和无限的运动方式。自信地举重，同时Peloton IQ计算次数、纠正姿势并跟踪你的进度。让自己奔跑、举重、流动并出发。在onepeloton.ca探索全新的Peloton交叉训练跑步机Plus。也许这只是你经历的一个阶段。你会克服它的。我帮不了你。
The next appointment is in six months. You're not alone. Finding mental health support shouldn't leave you feeling more lost. At CAMH, we know how frustrating it can be trying to access care. We're working to build a future where the path to support is clear, and every step forward feels like progress, not another wrong turn. Visit camh.ca to help us forge a better path for mental health care. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History.
下一次预约是在六个月后。你并不孤单。寻找心理健康支持不应该让你感到更加迷茫。在CAMH，我们知道试图获得护理是多么令人沮丧。我们正在努力建设一个未来，让获得支持的道路清晰可见，每一步前进都感觉是进步，而不是又一次错误的转弯。访问camh.ca帮助我们为心理健康护理开辟一条更好的道路。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。
We ended the first half with, of course, the storm clouds of war gathering, and they're gathering over the Baltic. And Dominic, people may be slightly puzzled about that because we've been talking a lot about the channel, the Atlantic, the Mediterranean. Earth is going on in the Baltic that would cause storm clouds together. Would you like some political context? I'd like you to pull the camera back. Oh, very good.
我们以战争风暴云的聚集结束了上半场，它们正聚集在波罗的海上空。多米尼克，人们可能会对此感到有些困惑，因为我们一直在谈论海峡、大西洋、地中海。波罗的海发生了什么会导致风暴云聚集？你想要一些政治背景吗？我希望你把镜头拉远。哦，非常好。
Very good. Okay, so the French Revolutionary Wars have broken out in 1792, and they've been going on forever. This latest phase, which began in 1798, is called the War of the Second Coalition. But despite all Nelson's heroics that then are, the second coalition has begun to break up. Because the coalition is between France's enemies, including Britain and Russia and Austria and Austria and the Russians, are both basically about to pull out of the war and sign treaties with the French. So that means that not for the last time, Tom, Britain stands alone. Stand alone for all that's good in this world. So now the seas are massively important,
非常好。好吧，法国大革命战争始于1792年，并且一直在持续。这最新阶段始于1798年，被称为第二次反法同盟战争。但尽管尼尔森有种种英雄事迹，第二次反法同盟已经开始瓦解。因为同盟是法国的敌人之间的，包括英国、俄罗斯和奥地利，而奥地利和俄罗斯基本上都要退出战争并与法国签署条约。这意味着，汤姆，英国再次孤立无援。为世界上所有美好的事物孤军奋战。所以现在海洋变得极其重要，
of course, for Britain. And they're even more important if you basically have no land allies because the sea is all you have. The Royal Navy has been. blockading the French coast to try and starve the French of trade and supplies. And in the long run, in the very, very long run, that's how we win the war, because we control the seas, we suffocate Napoleon, suffocate his economy, and we force him into mad gambols like invading Russia. Sad to say, not all of our European friends have respected this blockade. And a very good example is Denmark. Denmark has been flirting with a policy of armed neutrality. meaning they send warships to help their merchant ships break the brocade.
当然，对英国来说。如果你基本上没有陆地盟友，它们就更重要了，因为海洋是你拥有的一切。皇家海军一直在封锁法国海岸，试图切断法国的贸易和供应。从长远来看，非常、非常长远来看，这就是我们赢得战争的方式，因为我们控制了海洋，我们窒息了拿破仑，窒息了他的经济，并迫使他进行像入侵俄罗斯这样的疯狂赌博。遗憾的是，并非我们所有的欧洲朋友都尊重这种封锁。丹麦就是一个很好的例子。丹麦一直在奉行武装中立政策，
And then in late 1800, while Nelson is in the middle of the sort of Fanny Emma, imbrolio, there is a shocking new development. So one of our key, Britain's key second coalition allies, was Tsar Paul I of Russia. He is a very strange and disagreeable man. We like a strange and disagreeable Tsar, don't we? Yeah, well, we specialize in them, as does Russia. And he has, I think, he's sort of got all the worst aspects of Peter the Great and none of the good ones. So he loves massive military parades.
这意味着他们派遣军舰帮助他们的商船打破封锁。然后在1800年底，当尼尔森正处于范妮和艾玛的纠葛中时，出现了一个令人震惊的新进展。所以我们关键的、英国关键的第二次反法同盟盟友之一，是俄罗斯的保罗一世沙皇。他是一个非常奇怪且令人不快的人。我们喜欢奇怪且令人不快的沙皇，不是吗？是的，嗯，我们擅长这个，俄罗斯也一样。我认为他基本上拥有彼得大帝所有的缺点，却没有一个优点。所以他喜欢大规模的军事阅兵。
He loves flogging people. So Peter the Great People may remember was obsessed with beards and cutting people, you know, stopping them wearing kaffetans and they had to wear trousers. This guy, he doesn't approve of modern liberal clothing. He, in fact, bans, round hats, trousers, and lace up shoes. And he also believes that waistcoats contributed to the outbreak of the French Revolution. Because he thinks all of these things are kind of liberal, it's liberal coded dress. And it speaks of Republican sympathies. And he just doesn't like republicanism.
他喜欢鞭打人。所以人们可能还记得彼得大帝痴迷于胡须，剪掉人们的胡子，你知道，阻止他们穿卡夫坦长袍，他们必须穿裤子。这家伙，他不赞成现代自由服装。事实上，他禁止圆顶礼帽、裤子和系带鞋。他还认为背心导致了法国大革命的爆发。因为他认为所有这些东西都是某种自由的、自由编码的服装。这说明了共和主义的同情心。他只是不喜欢共和主义。
He doesn't like new ideas, all of this stuff. Right. So, which is why, obviously, why he would be fighting against France. Because France has a hotbed of waistcoats and ludicrous hats. But there's another side to him. He's obsessed with becoming, I mean, this is your Malta thing again, Tom is like you. He's obsessed with becoming the grand master of the Knights of St John. So when Britain did capture Malta in September 1800 and kept Malta for themselves,
他不喜欢新思想，所有这些东西。对。所以，这显然就是他为什么会与法国作战的原因。因为法国是背心和荒谬帽子的温床。但他还有另一面。他痴迷于成为，我的意思是，这又是你的马耳他问题，汤姆，就像你一样。他痴迷于成为圣约翰骑士团的大团长。所以当英国在1800年9月占领马耳他并将其据为己有时，
Zah Paul I first said, what? You know, what's this? You can't have Malta. And switch as sides. So you see, I'm right. Malta is key. You see, I think it's sad that we had to fight the Danes, and we had to crush, we had to teach the Danes a lesson. And this would not have happened if we hadn't taken Malta.
保罗一世沙皇首先说，什么？你知道，这是什么？你不能拥有马耳他。然后倒戈了。所以你看，我是对的。马耳他是关键。你看，我认为我们不得不与丹麦人作战，我们不得不粉碎、我们不得不给丹麦人一个教训，这很可悲。如果我们没有占领马耳他，这一切就不会发生。
Anyway, basically, Paul switches sides. He opens, talks with Bonaparte. And Bonaparte by this point is first consul, isn't he? So he's overthrown the directory. He's clearly basically the dictator now. So in December 1800, Paul signed a deal with the other Baltic powers. That's Denmark, Sweden and Prussia. And they set up a league of armed neutrality.
总之，基本上，保罗倒戈了。他与波拿巴展开了会谈。而波拿巴此时已经是第一执政了，不是吗？所以他推翻了督政府。他显然基本上已经是独裁者了。所以1800年12月，保罗与其他波罗的海国家签署了一项协议。那就是丹麦、瑞典和普鲁士。他们建立了武装中立联盟。
They will break the blockade of the Royal Navy and they will trade with the French. Now, clearly this is a massive threat to Britain's war effort. First of all, it would mean that Russia controls the Baltic. But also, it would give the French enough timber, enough hemp, enough iron to restock their navy, build loads of new ships, win back control of the seas potentially. Of course, if they did that, it's curtains for Britain and game over in the war. So to quote Andrew Lambert's great historian, if Britain accepted, she would abandon her great power status and accept French hegemony over Europe. These issues were fundamental
他们将打破皇家海军的封锁，并与法国进行贸易。现在，这显然是对英国战争努力的巨大威胁。首先，这意味着俄罗斯控制了波罗的海。但同时，它也会给法国提供足够的木材、足够的麻、足够的铁来补充他们的海军，建造大量新船，潜在地夺回海洋控制权。当然，如果他们那样做了，对英国来说就是完蛋了，战争也就结束了。所以引用伟大的历史学家安德鲁·兰伯特的话，如果英国接受，她将放弃她的大国地位，接受法国在欧洲的霸权。这些问题是根本性的
to Britain's very survival. So by December 1800, to the point at which Nelson is going off to William Beckford's slightly sordid party, you know, George III is telling the House of Commons, our honour and independence, our maritime interests, our security, all depend on not letting this happen. And this is upsetting for him, isn't it? Because he's got kind of, you know, he's related to the Danish royal family. He loves the Danes. So Denmark, since 1784, has been run not by its king because he's mad, but by his son, Crown Prince Frederick. And Crown Prince Frederick is George III's nephew. And George likes him. He likes the Danes. Everybody likes the Danes. So Nelson, he sees them as basically the best thing any foreigner can be the brothers of Englishmen.
对英国的生存至关重要。所以到1800年12月，在尼尔森要去参加威廉·贝克福德那个稍微有点肮脏的派对时，你知道，乔治三世正在告诉下议院，我们的荣誉和独立、我们的海上利益、我们的安全，都取决于不让这种情况发生。这让他很心烦，不是吗？因为他有某种，你知道，他与丹麦王室有亲戚关系。他喜欢丹麦人。所以丹麦自1784年以来，不是由它的国王统治，因为他疯了，而是由他的儿子，王储弗雷德里克统治。而王储弗雷德里克是乔治三世的侄子。乔治喜欢他。他喜欢丹麦人。每个人都喜欢丹麦人。所以尼尔森，他认为他们基本上是任何外国人能成为的最好的东西，英国人的兄弟。
Exactly. High praise. There was the highest praise. So they tried to negotiate, but while that's happening, the Admiralty says, look, we're going to have to send a fleet into the Baltic to show that we mean business. And your orders are capture or destroy the Danish fleet first. Because obviously, if we're sailing up the Baltic, Denmark comes first, then you go past Sweden, and then finally you get to Russia. And, you know, the orders are very clear. The Secretary of War, Henry Dundas, writes, we must show the Royal Navy is, and I quote, a match for the whole naval force of the world combined.
完全正确。那是最高的赞美。那是最高的赞美。所以他们试图谈判，但当这种情况发生时，海军部说，看，我们将不得不派遣一支舰队进入波罗的海，以表明我们是认真的。你的命令是首先俘获或摧毁丹麦舰队。因为显然，如果我们航行到波罗的海，丹麦是第一站，然后你经过瑞典，最后你到达俄罗斯。而且，你知道，命令非常明确。战争大臣亨利·邓达斯写道，我们必须证明皇家海军是，我引用，与世界上所有海军力量总和相匹敌的。
We have to rule the waves because we're so inconsequential on land that, you know, that's the only way we'll stay in this war. Now, this is made for Nelson, isn't it? I mean, this has got his name all over it. And he has been itching to get to sea. The weird thing is he begged to be sent back to England, begged and begged and made a nuisance of himself to Admiral Lord Keith. Then he got back to England and said, I can't wait to get back to sea again.
我们必须统治海洋，因为我们在陆地上太无足轻重了，你知道，那是我们留在战争中的唯一方式。现在，这是为尼尔森量身定做的，不是吗？我的意思是，这上面写着他的名字。他一直渴望出海。奇怪的是，他恳求被送回英国，恳求再恳求，并让基思海军上将感到厌烦。然后他回到英国，说，我迫不及待地想再次出海了。
Because, of course, he's a drift on land, isn't he? He's not at ease and he's got this terrible love triangle. Well, I think also going and having a crack at the Danes, it's simpler than having to ass around with Malta and, you know, Queens and all that. It's much more complicated. But I think the fact that Nelson is not appointed to the command, he's only given a role as deputy, does reflect the fact that back in London, his reputation has been tarnished. I think otherwise he would have been given command of it. I think it has. Whether he would be capable actually wielding sole command is an interesting question
因为，当然，他在陆地上漂泊，不是吗？他不自在，而且他有这个可怕的三角恋。嗯，我认为去和丹麦人较量一下，比不得不处理马耳他和，你知道，女王和所有那些事情要简单。这复杂得多。但我认为尼尔森没有被任命为指挥官，只被赋予了副手的角色，确实反映了他在伦敦的声誉已经受损的事实。我认为否则他会被授予指挥权。我认为确实如此。他是否有能力真正行使单独指挥权是一个有趣的问题
because he's, I mean, not for the first or the last time. He's in a bit of a terrible state, isn't he? He's had an attack of malarial fever. I always think when Nelson's so much of this physical stuff is psychosomatic to some degree. You know, he went to see his old patron, Sir John Jervis, who's now the Earl of St. Vincent. And Jervis was really shocked by Nelson's appearance. Poor man, he is devoured with vanity, weakness and folly.
因为他，我的意思是，不是第一次也不是最后一次。他处于一种可怕的状态，不是吗？他患过疟疾。我总是认为当尼尔森处于这种状态时，很多身体上的东西在某种程度上是心因性的。你知道，他去见了老赞助人约翰·杰维斯，他现在是圣文森特伯爵。杰维斯对尼尔森的样子感到非常震惊。可怜的人，他被虚荣、软弱和愚蠢所吞噬。
Well, that's what you want from the patron and father figure that you most admire in the Navy. From there, Nelson travels down to the dockyard at Plymouth, and there he has news at the end of January, beginning of February, that changes his life. Because probably on the 29th January, we can't be sure, Emma has finally given birth to a daughter. Do they acknowledge it? They don't. Well, they can't. How can you? Do they, are they so subtle that they give no hint as to whose daughter it might have been?
嗯，这就是你从海军中最钦佩的赞助人和父亲形象那里得到的评价。从那里，尼尔森前往普利茅斯的造船厂，在那里他在1月底、2月初得到了改变他一生的消息。因为可能在1月29日，我们不能确定，艾玛终于生下了一个女儿。他们承认了吗？他们没有。嗯，他们怎么能呢？他们是否如此微妙，以至于没有暗示这个女儿可能是谁的？
They call her Horatia. Horatia, yeah. And he sends Emma all these coded letters. They call themselves Mr. and Mrs. Thompson. And, I mean, this is the best thing. Nelson wrote to her and he said, I think, you know, it would be really nice. When you do the birth certificates, the name of the parents should be Johem and Marata Etnob. Etnob, Bronte.
他们叫她霍拉蒂亚。霍拉蒂亚，是的。他给艾玛发了所有这些加密信件。他们自称汤普森先生和夫人。而且，我的意思是，这是最好的部分。尼尔森写信给她说，我想，你知道，那会非常好。当你做出生证明时，父母的名字应该是Johem和Marata Etnob。Etnob，勃朗特。
This is a quote. if you read the surname backwards and take the letters of the other names, it gives the names of Horatio and Emma Bronte. This is him showing off about his dukedom. And that's classic Nelson. It's the sort of, he thinks he's being really subtle, but he obviously is just, it's laughable, but he's also boasting. Yeah, he wants to draw attention to it.
这是一个引用。如果你把姓氏倒过来写，并取其他名字的字母，它就给出了霍雷肖和艾玛·勃朗特的名字。这是他在炫耀他的公爵爵位。那是典型的尼尔森。这是一种，他认为自己非常微妙，但他显然只是，这很可笑，但他也在吹嘘。是的，他想引起人们的注意。
Yeah. So for the time being, this little girl is given to a woman called Mrs. Gibson. And Mrs. Gibson basically acts as her guardian, doesn't she? And obviously this massively intensifies the bond between Nelson and Emma, because Fannie hadn't been able to give him a child. And Nelson loves children. So he'd be very besotted with Horatia. Completely.
是的。所以暂时，这个小女孩被交给了一个叫吉布森夫人的女人。吉布森夫人基本上充当了她的监护人，不是吗？显然这极大地加强了尼尔森和艾玛之间的纽带，因为范妮没能给他生个孩子。而尼尔森喜欢孩子。所以他会对霍拉蒂亚非常着迷。完全是。
And actually, I think it's the fact that he's had the child and he can't see her contributes to his misery. Because these are some of the lowest weeks of his life. He's stuck in this new ship, the St. George in Torbay. The weather at the beginning of 1801 is absolutely terrible. It's kind of howling gale. driving rain. There's snowstorms and stuff. He's in this cabin on his own. He's really low. The newspapers are full of kind of gossip about him. There are cartoons that basically show Emma drinking gin. Massively pregnant. So there's a famous one of Emma as Dido, the Queen of Carthage, who gets abandoned by Aeneas, who sails off. And it's grotesquely unfair. And of course, is... very much drawing attention to the fact that she's pregnant. And so everybody knows what's going on.
而且实际上，我认为他有了孩子却见不到她，这加剧了他的痛苦。因为这是他一生中最糟糕的几周。他被困在这艘新船上，托贝的圣乔治号。1801年初的天气非常糟糕。这是一种咆哮的狂风。倾盆大雨。有暴风雪之类的。他独自待在这个船舱里。他真的很低落。报纸上到处都是关于他的八卦。有一些漫画基本上显示艾玛在喝杜松子酒。怀孕了。所以有一张著名的漫画，艾玛扮演迦太基女王狄多，她被埃涅阿斯抛弃，埃涅阿斯航行离开了。这极其不公平，当然，是……非常引人注目地强调了她怀孕的事实。所以每个人都知道发生了什么。
She's very large in these cartoons. And so William Hamilton often pops up in them, doesn't he, looking very beaky and weedy in the background. Whizzen. Yeah. And so very pervy. Now, the other thing about Nelson, that is actually, I do find this both sad and comical,
她在这些漫画里非常臃肿。所以威廉·汉密尔顿经常出现在里面，不是吗，看起来非常尖嘴猴腮。枯萎。是的。而且非常色情。现在，关于尼尔森的另一件事，实际上，我确实觉得这既悲伤又滑稽，
is he's absolutely tormented by jealousy. So a terrible development, a few days after Horatia's birth, Emma writes to him and says, I'm going to have dinner with the Prince of Wales, the future George the 4th. And Nelson, this is the worst news he's ever heard. Because the Prince Regents are a massive lech, isn't he? Yeah, he's a, he really is a terrible man, the Prince Regents.
是他被嫉妒折磨得死去活来。所以一个可怕的发展，在霍拉蒂亚出生几天后，艾玛写信给他，说，我要和威尔士亲王，未来的乔治四世共进晚餐。尼尔森，这是他听过的最糟糕的消息。因为摄政王是个大色狼，不是吗？是的，他确实是个可怕的人，摄政王。
And Nelson waits back, he says, I know his aim is to have you for a mistress. The thought so agitates me that I cannot write. I'm in tears, I cannot bear it. And there is so much like this, isn't there? He just goes on and on and on like this. This podcast could go on for hours. They're comical, actually. Do not let him touch you, nor sit next to you.
尼尔森回信说，我知道他的目的是让你做情妇。这个想法让我如此激动，以至于我无法写信。我泪流满面，我无法忍受。而且有很多这样的信，不是吗？他只是没完没了地这样写。这个播客可以持续几个小时。它们实际上很滑稽。不要让他碰你，也不要坐在他旁边。
If he comes, get up. God, strike him blind if he looks at you. And then this is so Nelsonian. They're then lurched from this into mad self-pity. Oh, God, that I was dead. Oh, God, why do I live? But the brilliant thing is that he's having to do the same with Emma, because Emma's massively jealous of him.
如果他来了，就站起来。上帝，如果他看着你，就让他瞎掉。然后这太尼尔森了。他们随后从这陷入了疯狂的自怜。哦，上帝，我死了就好了。哦，上帝，我为什么活着？但最棒的是，他不得不对艾玛做同样的事，因为艾玛非常嫉妒他。
So I think he goes to Portsmouth, and he's had to swear to Emma that he will spend no time with other women. And of course, he finds that he does. And so he writes back and confesses. So he describes one word. woman has dressed old you lamb fashion, so mutton dressed as lamb. Another looks like a cook made. Another likes a drop. Another is 55 deaf and pitted with smallpox. Oh, such gallantry. Yeah, exactly. And kind of mutual jealousy, again, seems to be kind of part
所以我认为他去了朴茨茅斯，他不得不向艾玛发誓，他不会和其他女人在一起。当然，他发现他确实在一起了。所以他回信并坦白了。所以他描述了一个女人打扮得像羔羊，也就是老妇装嫩。另一个看起来像个厨娘。另一个喜欢喝一杯。另一个55岁，耳聋，满脸天花疤。哦，真是风度翩翩。是的，完全正确。而且那种相互的嫉妒，似乎又是某种
of the rocket fuel of the relationship. Yeah, I think so. I think so. This is sort of a possessiveness and a paranoia combined. Now, meanwhile, what's happened to Fanny? Well, Fanny has not given up hope entirely. That's the sad thing. So she's heard from her son, Josiah, listeners may remember, saving Nelson's life and the attack in Tenerife when he lost his arm. Anyway, she's heard from Josiah that Nelson's eye infection has come back. And Fanny writes, and she says, I'd like to come and I'll be your affectionate nurse and look after you. And Nelson replies, you mean, you said Nelson behaves quite cruelly. I think this is very cruel, actually, from Nelson. He replies to her with an extraordinarily savage letter at the end of February.
关系的火箭燃料。是的，我想是这样。我想是这样。这是一种占有欲和偏执的结合。现在，与此同时，范妮发生了什么？嗯，范妮并没有完全放弃希望。这就是悲伤的地方。所以她从她的儿子乔赛亚那里听说了，听众可能还记得，在特内里费岛的袭击中，当他失去手臂时，他救了尼尔森的命。总之，她从乔赛亚那里听说尼尔森的眼部感染又复发了。范妮写信说，我想来，我会成为你深情的护士，照顾你。尼尔森回复说，你的意思是，你说尼尔森表现得相当残忍。我认为这实际上非常残忍，来自尼尔森。他在2月底给她回了一封极其野蛮的信。
He says, I'm going to pay you an allowance of £400 a quarter. And that is it, and I'm going to cut you off from this point onwards. I only wish people would never mention my name to you. I want neither nursing nor attention. Had you come here, I should not have gone on shore, nor would you have come afloat. Even if you'd come, I wouldn't even see you. I don't want to think about you anymore. I just want you out of my life.
他说，我要给你每季度400英镑的津贴。就是这样，从现在开始我要和你断绝关系。我只希望人们永远不要在你面前提到我的名字。我既不需要护理也不需要关注。如果你来这里，我就不会上岸，你也不会上船。即使你来了，我也不会见你。我不想再想你了。我只想让你从我的生活中消失。
So you talked about Nelson being cruel. Emma also, by this point, is behaving abominably to Fanny, kind of turning Nelson's family against her, calling her names, kind of gossiping about her behind her back. And I think both of them have kind of been driven mad by their mutual passion, but also by the social pressure that it has put both of them under. And I think this is the kind of the lowest point in their mutual story. they behave so badly to her. I completely agree with you, Tom. This is up to this point, Emma Hamilton, deep down, I'm going to confess, and I hope the listeners will not judge me for this, I find her quite annoying.
所以你谈到了尼尔森的残忍。艾玛此时也对范妮表现得极其恶劣，某种程度上把尼尔森的家人推向了她的对立面，叫她难听的名字，在背后议论她。我认为他们俩都被他们相互的激情所驱使，但也受到了社会压力，这给他们俩都带来了压力。我认为这是他们共同故事中的最低点。他们对她表现得太糟糕了。我完全同意你的观点，汤姆。这是到目前为止，艾玛·汉密尔顿，在内心深处，我要坦白，我希望听众不会因此评判我，我觉得她很烦人。
But this is the one point where I think she's genuinely vicious. Fanny is a beaten woman. Well, so Nelson, Nelson has this awful phrase. It is very easy to find a stick if you are inclined to beat your dog. Yeah, I mean, that's hard to defend. That's very hard to defend, I think. Now, I think in Nelson's case, I'm not saying this makes him better than Emma, by the way. But I think in Nelson's case, this is clearly driven.
但这确实是我认为她真正恶毒的一点。范妮是一个被打败的女人。嗯，所以尼尔森，尼尔森有这句可怕的话。如果你想打你的狗，很容易找到一根棍子。是的，我的意思是，这很难辩护。我认为这很难辩护。现在，我认为在尼尔森的情况下，我并不是说这让他比艾玛更好，顺便说一句。但我认为在尼尔森的情况下，这显然是受驱动的。
Do you not think by guilt? He hates feeling bad about himself. You know, he's been brought up by a vicar in a vicarage. He's been told how to behave. And he knows he's letting his father and his moral code down. There's a slight sense of viciousness and anger to the way he treats Fanny. Because he feels that she has driven him to behave badly and he doesn't like it. But what's interesting is he doesn't blame Emma for this.
你不觉得是因为内疚吗？他讨厌对自己感觉不好。你知道，他是由一位牧师在牧师住宅里抚养长大的。他被告知该如何表现。他知道他让他的父亲和他的道德准则失望了。他对待范妮的方式有一种轻微的恶毒和愤怒。因为他觉得她驱使他表现得不好，而他不喜欢这样。但有趣的是，他并没有因此责怪艾玛。
I mean, he could easily have done that. But actually, it seems to have forced them into an even greater kind of codependency, although it does not in any way inhibit his capacity to feel jealous, as we all see. Yeah, exactly. Now, I think one other aspect, actually, I mean, we could get bogged down in this. So one thing that is worth people remembering is Emma and Nelson can move on from this. They can still have their relationship. And the sad thing for Fanny is she can't ever move on and she never ever does because an abandoned wife can't take on a new partner.
我的意思是，他本可以很容易地做到这一点。但实际上，这似乎迫使他们进入了一种更大的相互依赖，尽管这并没有以任何方式抑制他感到嫉妒的能力，正如我们所见。是的，完全正确。现在，我认为另一个方面，实际上，我的意思是，我们可能会陷入其中。所以有一件事值得人们记住，艾玛和尼尔森可以从这件事中走出来。他们仍然可以维持他们的关系。而对范妮来说悲伤的是，她永远无法走出来，她也永远没有走出来，因为一个被抛弃的妻子不能再找一个新伴侣。
So she's effectively condemned to live as a kind of widow, as I think John Sugglin says, an object of pity and innuendo for the remainder of her days. And that is a really sad story. I mean, I suppose I'd say the one advantage she has over Emma is that, you know, we talked about Nelson making a financial settlement on her. she will get his pension in due course when he dies she's the one who will receive his prize money and so forth and this as we will see for Emma is going to be a catastrophe because she she does lack I mean Emma gets Nelson but she doesn't get the financial stability that Nelson gives to Fanny
所以她实际上被判处像一个寡妇一样生活，正如我认为约翰·萨格林所说，在她余生的日子里，成为怜悯和影射的对象。那是一个非常悲伤的故事。我的意思是，我想我会说她比艾玛的一个优势是，你知道，我们谈到了尼尔森为她做了经济安排。当他去世时，她会适时得到他的养老金，她是那个会收到他的奖金等等的人，正如我们将看到的，这对艾玛来说将是一场灾难，因为她确实缺乏，我的意思是，艾玛得到了尼尔森，但她没有得到尼尔森给范妮的那种经济稳定性
and that's quite a Jane Austen perspective on thinking it is yeah it is all right let's the end of that a very sad story let's get back to the action the 5th of March after Nelson has written his final sort of letter of dismissal to Fanny, he goes off to Yarmouth, which is on the Norfolk coast on the east of England, and there Admiral Hyde Parker's fleet is waiting. Nelson cannot wait to get into action to leave all this emotional drama behind. But in a sort of weird mirror image of what's been going on, Admiral Parker has an interesting love life of his own. He is 61 years old. He's a very kind of
那是一个非常简·奥斯汀式的视角，思考它，是的，确实是。好吧，让我们结束那个非常悲伤的故事，让我们回到行动中。3月5日，在尼尔森写完他给范妮的最后一封解雇信后，他去了雅茅斯，那是在英格兰东部的诺福克海岸，海德·帕克海军上将的舰队正在那里等待。尼尔森迫不及待地想采取行动，把所有这些情感戏剧抛在脑后。但以一种奇怪的镜像方式，海德·帕克海军上将也有他自己有趣的爱情生活。他61岁了。他是一个非常、
cautious, pedantic, meticulous admiral. But he's just married a new bride and her age is variously given at 24, remember he's 61, or by some sources as 18. There's a bit of a gap. Now, Admiral Hyde Parker loves, he's delighted. He's having a tremendous time and he's in no hurry to go sailing off to the Baltic when he's got this teenage bride. So while, you know, Nelson is chafing, Admiral Hyde Parker is organizing balls and parties and all this kind of thing, and so they don't set off for another week. But Dominic, the thing is that even when they do set off, and you'd think that Nelson's focus now would be all about the campaign to come, he's still obsessing about Emma, and he's still obsessing about the Prince of Wales and kind of writing letters to her all the time.
谨慎、迂腐、一丝不苟的海军上将。但他刚刚娶了一位新娘，她的年龄有各种说法，24岁，记住他61岁，或者有些来源说是18岁。有一点差距。现在，海德·帕克海军上将喜欢，他很高兴。他过得很愉快，当他有这个十几岁的新娘时，他一点也不急着去波罗的海航行。所以当，你知道，尼尔森在焦躁不安时，海德·帕克海军上将正在组织舞会和派对以及所有这些事情，所以他们又过了一周才出发。但是多米尼克，问题是即使当他们出发时，你以为尼尔森现在的焦点会全部放在即将到来的战役上，他仍然痴迷于艾玛，他仍然痴迷于威尔士亲王，并一直给她写信。
And I always think when I read about this campaign, and you read all the letters that he's sending to Emma, It's unbelievable that he has the focus and capacity to achieve what he achieves on this campaign. I mean, it's astonishing. Copenhagen is an amazing story, which we'll come to. The incredible thing is that basically build up to it, he's writing a letter saying, Sir William Hamilton's pimping you out. What are you doing? How are you associating with a set of whores, boards and unprincipled liars, all of this kind of thing?
我每次读到这次战役时，读到他发给艾玛的所有信件，我都觉得不可思议，他竟然有专注力和能力在这次战役中取得他所取得的成就。我的意思是，这太令人震惊了。哥本哈根是一个了不起的故事，我们将谈到它。令人难以置信的是，基本上在准备阶段，他写了一封信说，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士在为你拉皮条。你在做什么？你怎么能和一群妓女、无原则的骗子混在一起，所有这些事情？
He writes to about his dreams, doesn't he? He says, there's a dream in which I hit you over there with a stick, and then threw a tub of boiling hot water over you. Because of the prince. Yeah, that's a strange letter to get from your lover. I think Emma would roll with it. You reckon. Well, she clearly does.
他写信谈论他的梦，不是吗？他说，有一个梦，我在梦里用棍子打了你，然后把一桶滚烫的水泼在你身上。因为亲王。是的，那是一封从你的爱人那里收到的奇怪的信。我想艾玛会随遇而安的。你觉得呢。嗯，她显然做到了。
Well, it's the kind of, you know, the drama of it all, the melodrama. Now, meanwhile, as they sail northeast through the North Sea, the pace of events is quickening. On the 14th of March, the Admiralty sends them their final instructions. We want it to force the strait between Denmark and Sweden, annihilate the Danish fleet and the dockyards at Copenhagen. And if this isn't enough to intimidate the other Baltic powers, we want you to head on towards the Russian naval base at Kronstadt and hurry, hurry, you know, timers of the essence. So they sail on through this kind of driving rain and snowstorms. And on the 19th of March, they reached the northern tip of Jutland, which is called the score. And here they hear news that Britain's negotiating team has been expelled from Denmark.
嗯，这就是，你知道，这一切的戏剧性，情节剧。现在，与此同时，当他们向东北穿过北海航行时，事件的节奏正在加快。3月14日，海军部向他们发送了最终指示。我们想强行通过丹麦和瑞典之间的海峡，歼灭丹麦舰队和哥本哈根的造船厂。如果这还不足以恐吓其他波罗的海国家，我们想让你继续前往俄罗斯的海军基地喀琅施塔得，快点，快点，你知道，时间紧迫。所以他们穿过这种倾盆大雨和暴风雪继续航行。3月19日，他们到达了日德兰半岛的北端，被称为斯卡恩。在这里，他们听到消息说英国的谈判小组已被丹麦驱逐。
So there's no doubt now, it is war. So Admiral Parker sends a message home. He says, we will head around the tip of Jutland right away, and I will put the orders into execution. So round they go, and three days later, by the 22nd of March, they're approaching the town of Helsingur, better known as Elsinor, which is in the shadow of this great castle. One of the best gift shops I've ever been to in a castle.
所以现在毫无疑问，这是战争。所以帕克海军上将发回了一个消息。他说，我们将立即绕过日德兰半岛的尖端，我将执行命令。所以他们绕过去了，三天后，到3月22日，他们接近了赫尔辛格镇，也就是更著名的埃尔西诺，它在这一座大城堡的阴影下。这是我去过的城堡里最好的礼品店之一。
Yeah, it's a brilliant castle and a great gift shop. And, of course, this is famous in England as the setting for Shakespeare's play, Hamlet. And the salient thing about Hamlet, Dominic, is that he delays. And is there anyone in this story who delays, much to the impatience of Nelson? That's a very nice Shakespearean segue. I applaud that. I applaud that. That's top quality podcasting.
是的，这是一座辉煌的城堡和一个很棒的礼品店。当然，这在英国很有名，是莎士比亚戏剧《哈姆雷特》的背景。关于哈姆雷特，多米尼克，最突出的事情是，他拖延了。在这个故事里，有没有人拖延，让尼尔森非常不耐烦？这是一个非常好的莎士比亚式的过渡。我为之鼓掌。我为之鼓掌。这是顶级质量的播客。
Because right here, Admiral Parker stops. He hesitates. And the wind is with them. So why is he stopped? The answer is he's received terrifying new intelligence about the Danish defences. Copenhagen is already going to be a very tough nut to crack. The water is very shallow, and to get in an attacking fleet, get into the harbour, we'll have to go around this great shoal or sandbank called the middle ground.
因为就在这里，帕克海军上将停了下来。他犹豫了。风向对他们有利。那么他为什么停下来？答案是他收到了关于丹麦防御工事的令人恐惧的新情报。哥本哈根已经是一个非常难啃的骨头了。水非常浅，要进入攻击舰队，进入港口，我们将不得不绕过这个巨大的浅滩或沙洲，称为中间地带。
But Parker hears that the harbour entrance is guarded by this huge citadel batteries. There's two enormous forts that are built on wooden piles above the sea. a hundred guns each. And the Danes have lined the inner channel because they know the British are coming with warships and hulks and floating sort of gun platforms, which means that basically as you sail into the harvard, there's a wall of guns pointing right at you. I mean, to sail into that would be madness. It would effectively be suicide. What lunatic would conceive of doing that? Exactly. Who indeed? Parker thinks, no, no, no, it's just stop. And Nelson can't believe it. And for two days, he smoulders in his cabin aboard the St. George's ship. And he's still
但帕克听说港口入口处有巨大的堡垒炮台守卫。那里有两座巨大的堡垒，建在海上的木桩上，每座堡垒都有一百门大炮。丹麦人封锁了内航道，因为他们知道英国人会带着军舰、废船和浮动炮台前来，这意味着当你驶入港口时，基本上有一堵炮墙正对着你。我的意思是，驶入那种地方简直是疯了。这实际上等同于自杀。哪个疯子会想出这种主意？确实。到底是谁呢？帕克认为，不，不，不，必须停止。纳尔逊简直不敢相信。两天来，他一直闷闷不乐地待在圣乔治号的船舱里。他还在
writing letters to Emma? Yeah, exactly. He's thinking about the Prince of Wales and thinking about throwing boiling water over people's heads and stuff. And then he writes Parker this extraordinary letter. He says, don't worry about the defences. No, time is of the essence. It's now or never, we have to strike at the Danes. Not a moment should be lost. This is a quote in attacking the enemy. They will every day and every hour be stronger. And then he says to Parker, honour of England is in your hands. On your decision depends whether our country shall be degraded in the eyes of Europe or whether she shall rear her head higher than ever. Never did our country depend so much on the success of any fleet as on this. And he sends the letter across to Parker's
给艾玛写信吗？是的，没错。他在想威尔士亲王，想把开水泼在别人头上之类的事。然后他给帕克写了一封非同寻常的信。他说，别担心防御工事。不，时间至关重要。机不可失，时不再来，我们必须打击丹麦人。一刻也不能耽误。这是他在攻击敌人时说的一句话。他们每一天、每一小时都会变得更强大。然后他对帕克说，英国的荣誉掌握在你的手中。我们的国家在欧洲眼中是会蒙羞，还是会比以往任何时候都昂首挺胸，全取决于你的决定。我国从未像现在这样如此依赖一支舰队的成功。他把这封信送到了帕克的
flagship and he waits and waits for the reply and finally it comes. And Parker says, very well. We will attack. But you, Horatio Nelson, will lead that assault personally. I don't know. We're not going to stop now, are we? We are, Tom. That's the nature of podcasting. Unbelievable. Britain's survival is at stake. The Danish guns are bristling. Nelson's preparing to go into the straight. Oh, such excitement. And if you are a clubber member of the rest of history, then, of course, you can hear that episode right now, as well as the next four. four episodes in this series. And if you are not a club member, but you would like to become one, then you can go to the restishistory.com and sign up there. Unbelievable excitement. The Battle
旗舰上，他等待着，等待着回复，终于回复来了。帕克说，好吧。我们将发动进攻。但是你，霍雷肖·纳尔逊，将亲自领导这次突击。我不知道。我们现在不能停下来，对吧？我们要停了，汤姆。这就是播客的本质。难以置信。英国的生存岌岌可危。丹麦人的大炮严阵以待。纳尔逊正准备进入海峡。哦，太令人兴奋了。如果你是“历史其余部分”的俱乐部会员，那么当然，你现在就可以收听那一集，以及接下来的四集。本系列共有四集。如果你还不是俱乐部会员，但想成为会员，那么你可以去restishistory.com注册。令人难以置信的兴奋。这场战役
of Copenhagen is ready to begin. We will see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哥本哈根战役即将开始。我们下次见。再见。拜拜。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。